Wow!
You really came
out of nowhere.
What?
No.
No, I was stopped
at that stop sign.
Yeah.
Listen, let's just
exchange information
and have our insurance
companies take care of it.
Right.
Yeah.
I'm gonna get my info.
Yes, please.
Hey, no, what--
what are you doing?
What are you doing?
- Huh?
Why did you start the engine?
What engine?
The engine of your car.
Did I?
Yes.
I was just trying to get
the information for you
from the glove box.
Do you need to start your car
to open your glove compartment?
Uh...yeah?
Okay, you know what,
how about I just--
I get your insurance
information now.
- Right?
- Sure.
Hey, dude, no.
Hey--hey, hey--stop!
Stop, stop, stop!
Where the hell are you going?
Uh...nowhere?
Give me the information
right now!
- Okay.
- Right now.
Do you understand?
- Okay, okay.
All right, sorry.
I--I misunderstood.
I don't see how.
All right, here it is.
No, no, I--no.
Your--your insurance
information.
- I just did.
- This is a Walgreens receipt.
Ohhh.
Ohhh?
Here it is.
- "License to fart."
- [laughs]
Here it is.
What is that?
Now you're just miming.
You know what, give me
your insurance information
right now, or I'm
calling the cops!
- Okay, all right.
- Okay?
Okay, dude, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
That's just--
that's my personality.
I was messing with you.
I apologize.
I thought you were
gonna take off and--
and flee the scene.
Yeah, no, I'm not,
well.
Then how am I gonna
get my car fixed?
I--we just had an accident.
It's obviously not the time
or the place, so I'm--I'm sorry.
Here you go.
Here it is.
I mean, can you imagine,
though?
Yeah, that you were gonna
take off?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I can imagine that.
And it's giving me chills
up my fucking spine.
Anyway.
Here's the real insurance card,
and, uh...let me know
what you think.
"Official laminated license
to fart."
What the fuck--hey!
Hey!
No, hey!
(Keegan-Michael)
God damn it! Son of a bitch!
I am a sociopath!